that there is a question about why young
people aren't dating quite so much at
the moment uh a study showed that 86 of
women say they want a man to make the
first move
a different study said that 50 of men
say that they're afraid of making the
first move for being seen as creepy
another study said that 20 of gen
zetters say that a man approaching a
woman sometimes or always constitutes
harassment so you have a world in which
women are scared of being approached men
are scared of doing the approaching
people will judge many men at least one
in five men that do that as being
harasses but everybody understands that
if the guys don't make the first move
nothing's going to happen if guys do
make the first move they're scared of
being me too girls are scared of being
approached by guys that they don't know
but also still know that they need the
guys to make the first move 86 of the
time because that's the percentage
in that [__] interest